are Democrats losing Latino voters
that's what new polling suggests in
South Texas on a number of issues a
research poll from the Rio Grande Valley
to San Antonio asked voters the top
reasons they voted for a republican 40
percent said immigration 21 said they
just like the other candidate better and
17 percent said jobs
George Martinez is the Texas Coalition
director for the Libra initiative and he
joins us now George welcome to the show
um so let's talk about this because this
polling might be surprising especially
to some of the Consultants who were
Consulting Republicans you know a few
elections ago saying don't touch
immigration turns out Hispanics do care
about immigration and want more border
security at least those who are now
becoming Republicans
definitely first of all thank you so
much for having me Rachel it's a
pleasure to be here with you today so
what we are seeing is that the polling
is tracking with South Texas we do care
about the Border we live here and we
want our families to be safe we know
folks that work for Customs and Border
Patrol they are our family members
they're friends we go to church with
them one part of this is securing the
Border but the other part is also
improving legal access to come here for
those that want to contribute to our
society but the problem is we have a
Congress that is failing to act we need
both parties to work together because
one party alone does not get to decide
well border security and immigration
look like yeah sounds like we ought to
secure the Border first and then talk
about the other the other issues next
um you know one of the things that I
think doesn't get enough uh you know we
don't talk enough about is that this
acceleration of Hispanics towards the
Republican party and more conservative
ideas
um I think happened during covid I mean
so many Hispanic small businesses were
hurt Hispanics have much higher rates of
owning small businesses but also the
masking seems so elitist and you know
impacted service workers who tend to be
a lot of Hispanics
we are people that are hard-working we
want to work you know this is actually
an area that focuses a lot on energy so
we have folks that go to the oil fields
and when you have someone that is saying
that they want to end fossil fuels or
stop drilling we have folks that you're
now messing with their livelihoods so
that's a problem it's a message that is
not resonating so what you are seeing is
rejection of bad policy and instead the
acceptance of good policy a policy that
a pro-growth better for jobs and for low
taxes yeah very interesting there's a
natural home for them with conservatives
and the question is will that
acceleration towards the GOP continue
and help the benefit the Republicans
moving in to the next election George so
great having you here today
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis